bien et alors voilà ce voilà ce que
vient de faire monsieur jean jacques
pauvert il vient de publier sur sa de la
vanille je vais pas vous mentir 20 cet
ouvrage vous allez donner votre
sentiment non pas sauvage mais sur sur
le fait qu'il ait publié sept ouvrages
ils viennent vous êtes plutôt un éditeur
de gauche qui à présent vidées je l'aï
entendu dire vous savez c'est comme ça
mais c'est rageant est un dur ça ne veut
pas dire grand chose pour des
marguilliers blanc âgé des choses non
alors monsieur jean jacques prévert
vient de publier d'abord de remettre en
librairie les mémoires d'un fasciste est
d'abord les décombres de lucien rebatet
qui vous savez des fascistes et racistes
et il vient de publier un inédit c'est
la suite c'est bien ça vous reproduisez
l'as pikine et des mémoires de fascistes
sommes deux viennent de paraître aux
éditions pauvert ouvrage inachevé
d'ailleurs oui il va je n'ose lui alors
je récemment à beaucouzé publier ça
d'abord parce que c'est un site un
ouvrage excellent mon habit empêche de
dire que revêtait un an qu'on puisse
penser de ces idées était un très grand
écrivain les deux étendards sont connus
partout monde comme un roman un des
grands heureusement du siècle et lucien
rebatet et par dessus le marché un
personnage exemple comme il l'a dit il
l'a dit jusqu'à jusqu'à sa mort et l'a
proclamé jusqu'à sa mort il était fléchi
l'itinéraire de lucien rebatet
l'itinéraire de ce monsieur qui était un
grand écrivain qui était un homme
intelligent et y était celle qui était
fasciste
passionné il était fasciste dont il
était tout ce qu'on peut être quand on
efface east il était par conséquent il
était raciste
il était totalitariste il était pour un
gouvernement de minorité sur une sur une
major
vous savez le fascisme on connaît bien
les théories qu'il était tout ça et j'ai
publié ce livre d'abord parce que la
première partie dont vous parliez tout à
l'heure les décombres sans amener un
document extraordinaire france personne
n'a nié sur les années 38 à 40 sur
sur la débâcle français sur la drôle de
guerre surtout ce que moi j'étais assez
jeune enfin j'ai quand même j'ai quand
même des kills tout ça est depuis trente
ans j'entends dire les décombres sont un
document extraordinaire c'est vraiment
le meilleur livre me rends portable
c'était un grand journaliste bernard de
fallois dit c'était un grand journaliste
et j'ai cessé mon avis c'est un grand
document c'est ce qu'on a écrit meilleur
sur cette période
quel dommage qu'on ne puisse pas le
rééditer alors comme c'est une chose que
depuis 30 ans nudiste pour un certain
nombre des livres on m'a dit ça pour
m'avait dit ça pour le marquis de sade
on m'a dit ça quand j'ai fait des
certains certains journaux nuit dans le
fond je ne vois pas pourquoi vous ne
vais pas pourquoi est-ce que certains et
certaines doctrines est ce que certains
certains auteurs ce que certains esprits
seraient tenus dans un édito est géré
publié non seulement les décombres de
bol il va me la suis